[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis schönen guten Abend und
herzlich willkommen alles wichtig vom
Sport hat Norbert Lehmann für Sie
und das sind unsere großen Themen
schwieriger Spagat in der Außenpolitik
grünen Parteitag sucht neue Positionen
beim Thema Waffenlieferungen
schweres Grubenunglück in der Türkei 41
Bergleute sterben nach Explosionen im
Norden des Landes
und deutsche Sprinterin der Sonderklasse
Emma Hinze holt Silber bei der Bahnrad
Weltmeisterschaft
[Musik]
bei den Grünen dreht es sich heute auf
ihrem Parteitag vor allem um
Außenpolitik es ging um umstrittene
Themen wie Rüstungsexporte nach Saudi
Arabien aber auch in die Ukraine die
Grünen sehnen sich in ihrer Tradition
als Friedenspartei jetzt sitzen sie in
der Regierung und versuchen ihre Rolle
zu finden Patricia Wiedemeyer berichtet
es war die bisher emotionalste Rede des
Parteitages um mit nuripur in Iran
geboren nimmt die Situation der Frauen
im Iran zum Anlass grüne feministische
Außenpolitik zu definieren
wir sind nicht verhandelbar liebe
Freunde
genau das hatte auch Annalena baerbock
versprochen eine feministische
werteorientierte und pazifistische
Außenpolitik doch das lässt sich im
realen Leben nur schwer durchsetzen
spätestens mit den Waffenlieferungen an
die Ukraine
wir unterstützen die Ukraine humanitär
finanziell aber eben auch mit Waffen zur
Selbstverteidigung und zwar nicht obwohl
wir eine friedens- und
menschenrechtspartei sind sondern wir
unterstützen die Ukraine weil wir eine
friedens- und menschenrechtspartei sind
Waffenlieferungen an Saudi-Arabien
dagegen von der Ampel gerade beschlossen
von baerbock als Erbe der
Vorgängerregierung abgetan sind höchst
umstritten ebenso wie Geschäfte mit
undemokratischen Staaten geht es um die
Energieversorgung ist die Unterdrückung
und Verfolgung von Frauen und Queen
Menschen in Länder wie Saudi-Arabien und
der Katar plötzlich kein Thema mehr die
Zeiten Wände muss auch gegenüber China
formuliert werden wenn es falsch war
sich von Putin abhängig zu machen wie
kann es denn richtig sein Abhängigkeiten
gegenüber Siegen bringen dich zu
thematisieren
bei aller Kritik am Ende folgt die grüne
Basis den Vorgaben der parte in Sachen
Außenpolitik wie auch gestern am späten
Abend beim Streit Thema Atomenergie zwei
AKW dürfen als Reserve bis Mitte April
2023 weiterlaufen dann soll endgültig
Schluss sein
die Grünen haben also enge Grenzen
gesteckt was eine Verlängerung der
AKW-Laufzeiten angeht die Koll in Berlin
morgen soll es ein Gespräch zwischen
Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck
Finanzminister Lindner und Kanzler
Scholz geben der Streit ist ja
festgefahren ist ein
kompromissvorstellbar
also vorab kann ich jedenfalls
bestätigen dass wirklich für morgen ein
Treffen der drei koalitionsmatadore
geplant ist und zur Frage nach einem
vorstellbaren Kompromiss einerseits
scheint der Parteitagsbeschluss dass
jetzt kaum noch zuzulassen andererseits
aber ist es ja nach den Verhärtungen und
Verletzungen bei Grünen und FDP schier
unmöglich das eine Seite komplett
einknickten wird also wenn man es
realpolitisch durchdeklinierten gilt
erstens der Weiterbetrieb der beiden AKW
im Süden ist jetzt unstrittig und vom
grünen Parteitag abgenickt zweitens der
Kauf neuer Brennstäbe wurde von den
Grünen ja als rote Linie definiert und
ist damit undenkbarer denn je also
gesucht wird ein Angebot an die FDP das
könnte vielleicht doch noch das dritte
AKW im Emsland auf den Verhandlungstisch
bringen wobei das dann mitten in die
koalitionsverhandlung in Niedersachsen
platzen würde insgesamt sitzen die
Grünen aber am längeren Hebel denn wenn
es keine Einigung gibt dann laufen alle
AKW automatisch zum Jahresende aus
Einschätzung von theocall danke schön
die USA haben ein neues Sicherheitspaket
für die Ukraine angekündigt Munition und
Militärfahrzeuge im Wert von 725
Millionen Dollar russland hat
unterdessen Soldaten nach Belarus
geschickt für eine gemeinsame Truppe sie
solle die Villa russische Grenze
schützen heißt es aus Minsk beobachter
halten ein Eingreifen von Belarus in den
Krieg im Moment für unwahrscheinlich
in der Ukraine ist immer noch nicht die
Gefahr gebannt die vom AKW saporicia
ausgeht es ist in der Hand russischer
Besatzer
derzeit stehen alle sechs Reaktoren
still die Internationale
Atomenergiebehörde teilte mit das
Personal bereite sich darauf vor zwei
Reaktoren wieder hochzufahren manche
fachleute schätzen die Gefahr eines
Atomunfalls größer ein als die eines
russischen Angriffs mit nuklearen Waffen
Katrin Eugendorf
pedrocotin kann noch telefonisch Kontakt
halten zum Management von saparice der
Präsident der ukrainischen
Atomenergiebehörde war selbst einst
Direktor des Meilers der zunehmende
Druck auf die Mitarbeiter besorgt ihn
das Personal sollte sich um die nukleare
Sicherheit kümmern das ist seine Aufgabe
und jetzt sitzen sie da abgelenkt von
all den Waffen die auf sie gerichtet
sind
seit Wochen warnt Raphael grossi vor der
Gefahr der Chef der Internationalen
Atomenergiebehörde hatte sich zuletzt in
mit Putin persönlich getroffen um zu
vermitteln doch das Ziel eine
Sicherheitszone um Europas größten
Atommeiler zu schaffen ist nicht
erreicht
ich würde sagen ein radioaktiver Unfall
ist sehr nah und wir waren drei Mal
bereits ganz nah dran
[Musik]
seit einem Monat ist der atommaler
abgestellt doch immer wieder werde die
Stromversorgung zur Kühlung der
Brennstäbe unterbrochen damit drohten
eine Kernschmelze und Kettenreaktion
ähnlich wie im japanischen Fukushima
2011 warnt cotin
es gibt eine Menge nukleares Material es
wäre sicherer wenn wir all das nukleare
Material von saparese wegbringen würden
an einen sicheren Ort das Moskau den
Atommeiler am 5 oktober unter russische
Kontrolle gestellt habe sei ein weiteres
Problem für die Sicherheit von Europas
größtem Atommeiler
nach Deutschland ein Blackout sei ein
realistisches Szenario sagte der
Hauptgeschäftsführer des Deutschen
Städtetages dddsz die Bevölkerung müsse
stärker über mögliche Folgen von
Energieknappheit oder Sabotage
informiert werden
bundesinnenministerin Phaser forderte
die Betreiber von Einrichtungen der
kritischen Infrastruktur auf mehr für
die Sicherheit zu tun sie müssten massiv
investieren um mehr Backup-Systeme
vorzuhalten sollten die Hauptsysteme
ausfallen sagte Phaser der Frankfurter
Allgemeinen Sonntagszeitung
den Energiekrise treibt die Inflation
Gasstrom Lebensmittel alles wird teurer
die Folge immer mehr Menschen können
sich immer weniger leisten
gegen die steigenden Energiepreise
demonstrierten heute bundesweit tausende
wie hier in Leipzig
Protest auch in Berlin vor dem
Kanzleramt versammelten sich die die
Krise wohl am härtesten trifft dieser
Jani berichtet
ich bin armutsbetroffen und ich schäme
mich nicht mehr dafür sie ist
alleinerziehende Mutter und bezieht
Arbeitslosengeld 2 sie will wie so viele
hier am Kanzleramt dem abstrakten Wort
Armut ein Gesicht eine Stimme geben der
Rudern wir verzichten wir
stagnieren wir resignieren
wir erkranken
armutsbetroffen ist viel es begann mit
einem Hashtag den sie im Mai diesen
Jahres auf Twitter postete und der zur
Bewegung wurde ich bin armuts betroffen
mein Geld reicht nur noch für
Lebensmittel ich möchte einmal im Monat
meine Mutter besuchen das sind immer 50
Euro Fahrgeld und das ist nicht mehr
drin es ist wirklich so dass ich zum 20
mittlerweile sagen kann okay Obst und
Gemüse ist nicht mehr sondern halt nur
noch
harte Lebensmittel also wie Nudeln und
so sind es immer mehr die auf die
Lebensmittelspenden der Tafel angewiesen
sind schon jetzt gelten 13,8 Millionen
Menschen in Deutschland als
armutsgefährdet ich fürchte dass durch
die Pandemie durch die
Energiepreis Explosion und durch die
Inflation
sich die Armut zunehmend in die Mitte
der Gesellschaft hinein ausbreitet und
das heißt eben auch
mittelschichtfamilien werden betroffen
sein und Menschen die bisher glaubten
von Armut in keiner Weise tangiert zu
sein
auf der Bühne vor dem Kanzleramt
sprechen heute nur Betroffene sie
fordern unter anderem höhere Regelsätze
und vor allem dass man mit ihnen spricht
nicht nur über sie
jetzt wo die corona-infektion Zahlen
wieder kräftig steigen werden die Rufe
nach einer maskenpflicht Innenräumen
immer lauter nach
Bundesgesundheitsminister Lauterbach und
der Ärzte Gewerkschaft Magdeburger Bund
dringen nun auch die Kliniken auf eine
rasche Einführung an den meisten
Krankenhäusern sei der Normalbetrieb
nicht mehr möglich so Gas von der
Deutschen Krankenhausgesellschaft über
eine maskenpflicht in Innenräumen müssen
die Länder entscheiden
Bundeskanzler Scholz hat erneut für eine
deutliche Erweiterung der Europäischen
Union geworben eine EU mit 27 30 36
Staaten können ihr Gewicht in der Welt
noch stärker zu Geltung bringen dass der
Verbund Richtung ostenwachse sei ein
Gewinn so Scholz beim Kongress der
Sozialdemokratischen Partei Europas er
war auch dafür dass Prinzip der
Einstimmigkeit bei bestimmten
Entscheidungen abzuschaffen
in die Türkei dort sind bei einer
Explosion in einem Bergwerk 41 Menschen
ums Leben gekommen das Unglück ereignete
sich im Norden des Landes in der
Hafenstadt am masra am Schwarzen Meer in
der Kohlemine soll sich ersten Hinweisen
zufolge einen Gasgemisch entzündet haben
in der Türkei kommt es immer wieder zu
schweren Gruben Unglücken Lück Weipert
berichtet
dichter Rauch stieg auch heute aus dem
grubenschacht in amersra am Schwarzen
Meer auf gestern Abend befanden sich
mehr als 100 Bergleute in zwei Stollen
300 Meter unter der Erde als sich die
Explosion ereignette die Bergleute die
es unversehrt ins Freie schafften
standen unter Schock das war alles
dunkel voller Rauch wir haben nichts
mehr gesehen auch mit der Lampe nicht
es war schrecklich mir fehlen die Worte
es ist einfach traurig das waren unsere
Freunde da unten klar wir haben die
Wochenenden immer zusammen verbracht
28 zum Teil schwer Verletzte wurden in
umliegende krankenhaushäuser gebracht
die Behörden gehen von einer
methangasexplosion aus
das Feuer im Stollen so der
Energieminister heute früh ist
weitgehend eingegrenzt und unter
Kontrolle
wegen mangelhafter
Sicherheitsvorkehrungen kommt es immer
wieder zu schweren Grubenunglücken in
der Türkei vor acht Jahren starben im
südtürkischen Sommer 301 Arbeiter wir
sind als Nation sehr traurig sagt der
Präsident Erdogan bei seinem Besuch am
Unglücksort erkundigte eine gründliche
Untersuchung an um die Schuldigen zu
ermitteln
das Wichtigste war jetzt so schnell wie
möglich alle Opfer aus dem Schach zu
holen
wir haben leider auch den 41 Arbeiter
tot geborgen
den Familien der Opfer drückte Erdogan
sein Mitgefühl aus er kündigte rasche
finanzielle Entschädigungen an
denn ihr längster Fluss der Welt ein
Magnet für Reisender und die Lebensader
für die mehr als 100 Millionen
EinwohnerInnen Ägyptens aber denn hier
wird zunehmend mit Plastik verseucht ein
Thema ab morgen auf der wasserwoche in
Kairo kurz vor der Weltklimakonferenz im
November das Plastik im Nil vor allem
ein Problem für die zigtausend Fischer
im Land wie Peter Theisen berichtet
normalerweise angelt abdussaithier
Buntbarsche und Welse aus dem Nil doch
der Fluss gibt längst nicht mehr so viel
her wie früher und so Fisch der nun
stattdessen vor allem Plastik
wir sammeln hier nicht nur
Plastikflaschen sondern auch anderen
Müll aus dem Nil das wichtigste ist denn
nie wieder sauber zu kriegen denn dann
werden auch wieder mehr Fische hier
leben
doch vorerst hängt sein Einkommen auch
vom Plastik ab an manchen Tagen sammelt
er 20 oder 30 Kilo aus dem Fluss die
Flaschen geben er und 60 weitere Fischer
bei einer kleinen Firma am nienufer ab
die Flaschen werden zusammengepresst und
weiterverkauft an eine Fabrik die
Granulat daraus macht jeder Fischer
bekommt dafür etwa 150 Euro im Monat
[Applaus]
eine Studie des Umweltministeriums
schätzt dass es bereits 2030 mehr
Plastik als Fisch im Nil geben wird das
ist ein Riesenproblem auch für uns denn
dieser Müll verursacht einen weiteren
Rückgang der Bestände denn die Fische
fressen das Plastik und sterben daran
ein Pfandsystem gibt es in Ägypten
genauso wenig wie eine gut
funktionierende Müllabfuhr das
plastikproblem wächst im Land der
Pharaonen haben Sie deshalb nun ein Mann
mal errichtet eine Pyramide aus Ballen
von plastikmüllen
die meisten Menschen haben keine Ahnung
wie viel Plastikmüll an einem einzigen
Tag anfällt sie wissen gar nicht wie
groß das Problem ist
auch abdosait hofft auf mehr Bewusstsein
ein Ende der Vermüllung und irgendwann
wieder mehr Fische im Nil der Plastik
verseuchten Lebensader Ägyptens
nach fast sechs Monaten auf der
Internationalen Raumstation ISS ist ein
Team aus astronautenen und Astronauten
aus den USA und Italien zur Erde
zurückgekehrt die Kapsel des
Raumschiffes landete Atlantik vor der
Küste Floridas es ist das vierte
astronautenteam das von Elon Musk
weltraumunternehmen SpaceX zur
Raumstation und zurückgebracht wurde
zur Bahnrad-WM in Frankreich Norbert da
war ja immer Hinze wieder erfolgreich
diesmal Silber im Zeitfahren über 500
Meter damit hat sie ihre Medaillensatz
vervollständigt aber eigentlich wollte
sie ja natürlich ihr zweites Gold bei
dieser WM holen doch eine junge
französische Konkurrentin die war
überraschend stark
rund zwei Zehntel fehlen immerhin zu
ihrem zweiten WM-Titel auf der
Olympiabahn von Paris 2024
es ist schon ein bisschen schade und ich
habe halt gedacht kann noch mal
schneller fahren und es ist halt nicht
so warm war ich schon enttäuscht in der
Qualifikation Hinze noch die schnellste
daher im Finale als letzte auf der Bahn
über die 500 Meter ihr beherzt das
Schlusssprint sichert der deutschen
Silber die erst 20-jährige
Lokalmatadorin marie de Mar courmet
damit neue Weltmeisterin im Zeitfahren
in der Fußball-Bundesliga geht es für
die Eintracht weiter nach oben und für
die Bayer 11 weiter nach unten hier die
bisherigen Ergebnisse des Zehnten
Spieltags Frankfurt schlägt Leverkusen
mit 5:1 Bremen unterliegt Mainz 0:2
Wolfsburg und Gladbach trennen sich 2:2
Stuttgart gewinnt im Kellerduell gegen
Bochum klar mit 4:1 das Abendspiel
Leipzig gegen Hertha bereits gestern
verlor Schalke gegen Hoffenheim mit 0:3
morgen Köln gegen Augsburg ja und zwei
echte Spitzenspiele Tabellenführer Union
empfängt den BVB und die Bayern den SC
Freiburg die Tabelle ganz oben
unverändert Union erster Freiburg
zweiter für Hoffenheim und Frankfurt
geht's rauf auf die Plätze 3 und 4 die
Bayern fünfter dahinter Gladbach und
Dortmund die zweite Tabellenhälfte
beginnt mit Köln und unten hat sich der
VfB etwas Luft verschafft jetzt 14
Leverkusen rutscht runter auf Rang 16
vor Schalke und Schlusslicht Bochum
und das Abendspiel Leipzig gegen Hertha
ausführlich bei uns zu sehen Aktuellen
Sportstudio um 23 Uhr zu Gast Gladbach
dfb-nationalspieler Jonas Hoffmann ja
und gestern Abend das Derby der zweiten
Liga pauli gegen den HSV der
überraschende 130 Sieg der Kiezkicker
wurde überschattet von
Auseinandersetzung mit der Polizei vor
dem Spiel
ein Video aus den sozialen Netzwerken
das einen St Pauli Fan zeigen soll der
offenbar zum Opfer von Polizei Gewalt
wird was zuvor geschah und warum die
Polizisten gewalttätig Vorgehen ist noch
unklar viele Anhänger des Vereins
reagierten empört insgesamt wurden im
Rahmen des Derbys 47 Personen in
Gewahrsam genommen der FC St Pauli
stellt in den sozialen Netzwerken die
Frage der Verhältnismäßigkeit und
fordert Aufklärung sportlich
triumphierte der Verein und fügte dem
HSV eine bittere 3:0-niederlage zu David
Otto setzte in der 89 minute den
Schlusspunkt zum gewalttätigen Vorfall
außerhalb des Stadions merkt die
Hamburger Polizei an warum der Kollege
der Bundespolizei in dem Moment
unmittelbaren Zwang angewendet hat und
vor allem ob das in der Gesamtsituation
auch rechtmäßig war und verhältnismäßig
war das müssen wir jetzt tatsächlich im
Nachhinein prüfen es ist eine
Strafanzeige gefertigt worden gegen den
Kollegen und im Rahmen dieser Ermittlung
wird man dann zu einem Ergebnis kommen
wie Überprüfung der Verhältnismäßigkeit
ja das war zum Sport Dankeschön Norbert
ein ausgesprochen Melder Oktober Sonntag
wird das morgen wo die Sonne scheint und
wo ist regnet zeigt Ihnen gleich Katja
horneffer das heute journal können Sie
an diesem Abend um 22:45 Uhr sehen mit
Christian Sievers schönen Abend noch
[Musik]
guten Abend es ist viel los am Himmel
über Mitteleuropa Morgen bringt dir
dieses Tief hier dichtere Wolken in der
Mitte Deutschlands und da fällt auch
etwas Regen und danach wird es bei uns
richtig warm in der Nacht wird es jetzt
erstmal regnen nicht mehr so viel wie in
der vergangenen und zwar zwischen
Baden-Württemberg und Thüringen und auch
in Schleswig-Holstein sind einige
Schauer nicht ganz ausgeschlossen am
Alpenrand kann sich auch mal Nebel
bilden dort sinken die Werte auf 7 Grad
sonst bleibt es bei 13 bis 9 Grad milder
und morgen wird ein sehr milder
Oktobertag hier zwischen der Ostseeküste
und der Mosel steigen die Temperaturen
auf 16 bis 18 Grad zwischen Brandenburg
und dem Bodensee werden sogar 20 bis 25
Grad erreichen beim wärmsten wird es im
Südwesten und Süden dort scheint die
Sonne auch am stärksten über der Mitte
da halten sich dagegen dichtere Wolken
und die bringen eben auch den bisschen
Regen mit in Nordfriesland da kann es
vielleicht am Vormittag noch für einen
kleinen Regenschauer reichen noch wärmer
wird an der Montag wir erwarten bis zu
26 Grad besonders Richtung Sachsen ganz
südliches Brandenburg auch in Sachsen
vielleicht auch in Thüringen danach
kommt eine kleine kalt von Nordwesten
heran die breitet sich am Dienstag
südwärts aus am Mittwoch liegen die
Werte bei 12 bis 19 Grad schönes
Wochenende